hi I'm Toby Young I'm the new editor of
spectator life one of these supplements
the spectator producers which is being
given away free with this week's issue
and there's plenty to read we've got a
wonderfully seditious profile of Afghani
leopard f the owner of the dependent and
evening standard by Freddie gray with
lots of juicy tidbits such as the fact
that he once went on a doll's house diet
which involved trying to eat less by
eating with tiny dold cutlery we've got
a fabulous profile of Alan Yentob by
Marion Jones and X Newsnight producer
about en tubs future and whether it's in
some doubt now because of his links to
the kids company scandal regular new
column I've introduced called pundits in
peril in which conservative journalists
and commentators write about how they
take their life in their hands when they
appear on the BBC on programs like news
night or any questions we've got a piece
by joshi herrmann on why london's tech
city hasn't yet produced a google or an
amazon and is in fact a bit of a
backwater we've got a very very tasty
piece by Alex Wickham of guido fawkes
fame about the havoc being wreaked by
the SNP's barmy army of MPs at
Westminster so there's plenty to read
you get it free with the current issue
of The Spectator